breaking matter in my life have I been
invited to somebody's Christmas well
that to me says that you're a bad friend
and they don't want you at their party
you're living in some sort of fantasies
ah Christmas the presents the family the
feasts the hustle and bustle what a trip
but is it worth it because I recently
heard tell of Jewish Christmas and I got
to be honest they might be on to
something
Christmas versus Jewish Christmas it's
debatable
I'm a Jew but I'm Pro Christmas I'm
arguing for Jewish Christmas Christmas
Christmas will always win there's a fair
comparison but I'd go for Jewish
Christmas if I had to pick good
old-fashioned regular Christmas I am
team Jewish Christmas and my opponent is
a traitor to her own kind it's a day of
movie marathons you know movies come out
on Christmas the best movies
well well Christians are busy hanging
out with their families forced to hang
out and do family [ __ ] I'm gonna be
seeing Star Wars for the third time have
you ever gone to a Chinese restaurant on
Christmas as a Jewish person hours of
wait really angry Jews it's every single
person with nowhere to go taking up so
much space so much time sounds like
you're at the wrong Chinese restaurant
with the wrong Jews Christmas is one of
those holidays that you always have to
go see your distant relatives every year
it's something different
how's college going oh you're graduating
what's your plan I'm excited to eat all
this Chinese food right here
chow mein orange chicken nothing says
like this is festive like food you would
order to your dorm room I got some
Malibu in 20 minutes I want with a few
friends guess who was on the beach
nobody except for us if there is no
traffic in LA it's amazing
you can drive wherever you want just for
the [ __ ] of it
the majority of Jews are not in LA
they're all I'm you know a good you I'm
a good ole suburban Jew and they were
[ __ ] nothing to do there Chinese
foods a lot better than Christmas food
like I would take lo mein over this
stupid ass you think you think this
looks worse than a fortune cookie are
you crazy
putting dinner at 3:00 p.m. just because
it's a holiday is absolutely absurd by
five o'clock when I should be having
dinner I'm already hungry again no
actual reality of Jewish Christmas is
you have to all agree on a movie with
your family with your family friends yet
you all have it I saw Benjamin Button
you defeated Benjamin Button I saw
look what we have here we have some box
these are empty there's not even
anything in here which I think you know
represents Jewish Christmas is that it's
empty of emotion I've done Jewish
Christmas and I've done Christmas
Christmas
once you go Christmas you never go back
Christmas Day comes boom you wake up
you're stoked you're in your PJs your
family is all gathered in the living
room and it's it's beautiful look at
these cute ass snowmen look at these
beautiful gorgeous like what time of
year is it totally excusable other than
Christmas just eat all this and it's
okay and you can gain weight because
you're layering your clothes
Thanksgiving we're having so much fun
cuz we love Christmas
they look Jewish do you want white rice
or do you want cookies you want to make
a gingerbread house do you want
everything to smell like cinnamon and
open presents I am happy that I can
participate in Christmas because of my
like dual citizenship in the religion
world you know yeah that's it but that's
it you get to be selective about the
parts of Christmas you get you celebrate
you don't have to do the whole shebang
you know what I mean you know I used to
wake up and think maybe Santa made a
mistake and maybe he gave me presents
this year
and you know what he never did never do
Santa doesn't make mistakes that's all
you're you're Jewish you've never
experienced Christmas Christmas yeah and
in fact it's what I want it so badly
hated Christmas before my parents got
divorced okay there's got so when it's
Christmas Christmas there's this
mentality of this day has to be great no
there's I've been to people's houses
like after they're all Christmas thing
they're like this is what I got I got
this I got this there's wrapping paper
everywhere the fire is blazing there's
just a sense of warmth movie theaters
are cold movie theaters are cold and
they're playing Benjamin Button
Christmas don't knock it till you've
tried it from a girl with the last name
Livie the actual spirit of Christmas has
been completely lost and I stand firm in
my belief that it's better to be Jewish
on Christmas shut up Christmas is the
best coming from a Jew it's the best I'm
just here to promote today the idea that
Jews have it pretty good too
also I hate Sarah I'm so mad